that that's what I was going to say man
recently obviously uh it was so awesome
to
see uh obviously the long everybody ever
since the full send podcast launch was
waiting on you to go on there so it was
dope to see you guys chat and kind of
talk about um the good old days and some
of the early pranks that you guys had
and then they kind of you gave it a
listen yeah I watched the whole thing
yeah I think the day
uh and then I watched the uh the New
York one where you guys were security
guards oh yeah yeah very it just was
like
nostalgic I get a lot of people have hit
me up since that video and been like
yeah it was like the perfect nostalgic
thing to do together that like brought
back like cuz a lot of people I think
they they got brought into NK because of
that Coachella video we did so it was
like their like first [__] thing they
seen so they were just stoked to see
that yeah I just like I think that
that's what I miss you guys I just miss
that kind of content cuz cuz it doesn't
really exist anymore and I don't think
Kyle's focused on making that kind of
[__] anymore and so it was just dope to
see you know what I mean feeding off
each other kind of yeah and just you
know like I I I I just think some of you
guys' pranks were just some of the best
[__] like you guys would really like you
know whether it's you and and uh Steve
obviously Steve's face I don't even
think it'd be shown anywhere on YouTube
from what I've heard right not even his
hand man it's [__] sad not even his
hand apparently I heard that yeah he
talk about doing a podcast with him or
something he' be off camera and like or
that's what it was I think he did the
Donald Trump one or something happened
and his hand was in it and they were
like flagging it it was like what it's
[__] Bonkers dude that poor guy man I
really feel bad for him because
like sweet dude and he was doing so much
like look he was doing some like pushing
the limit type [__] but he also was
giving away so much money to like random
families like I remember he had that
random lady he was taking on the road
with him everywhere the black like I
always thought I mean I I I miss him on
YouTube I haven't checked him out on
Rumble to see if the pranks or the
videos are still of of uh the quality
that they were but yeah when you're
deplatformed it's hard to I don't know
like
recognize I think it was cuz it was his
like audio but then they were like oh
he's not in it and then they said no
like I think they used like his hand
being it I could be [__] wrong but I
remember hearing that somewhere but well
um how how good did it feel for you to
kind of uh give the fans some
transparency you know and and so good I
bet right [__] cuz it was a long time
coming I remember uh we shot a video on
the Sunday Channel like driving up to
the house to go do it yeah and uh they
were just F like flogging me like the
team and I said this like thing and it's
so true I was like I'm so glad that this
is the [__] full send podcast that
we're going to do where we're like we're
cool and we're like like we're in good
terms me and Kyle and like not that
we're we we were in bad terms but like
it was definitely we went through deal
yeah it was a [__] thing and I didn't
want it to be some [__] mess on the
internet like you see a lot of people
who are in this social media game and
it's like they almost ride it as like oh
those so like we could use this for
views yeah and neither of us like even
him like we both were like this is some
business [__] we're going to figure this
out and then I don't know we did and now
we're cool it's like I mean I think it's
a mix of like reconnecting with him
personally for me but reconnecting with
the whole team shooting a prank again
doing the podcast being able to like
actually say how it is to all my
audience and Their audience and our old
fans and like dude it just feels like it
literally felt like a weight off my back
cuz like you know it's like drinking and
lifestyle and friends and everything
that I fixed in my life there was like
that one thing that I was like needing
to knock off the [__] list it just
feels like it's done now yeah and I
think it's cool too because now you guys
can like I I feel like you guys were
purposely kind of like you know I think
Kyle did a good job of not speaking too
much on it and I think even I heard in
an interview or somewhere he had said I
don't really want to dive into it until
yeah I talk with Jesse on the podcast
that's the fans deserve that you know
what I mean I think it was that money
buys happiness podcast he like yeah cuz
I watched that and I was like oh [__] I
guess this is where it's all coming out
and then he was just like he's always
just been respectful that way and I'm
like that's why I've treated him the
same way 100% yeah I think it's dope
just to see that man and like you said
the fans get a little closure cuz you
guys share fans I mean obviously you are
when I think of n boys I think of you
and him that's who I think of and Steve
to you know to an extent you know um but
it's dope man um for you though
like have you gotten the itch to like
kind of you know maybe pop in a video
here and there you know like yeah the so
Kyle hit me up and was like after we
shot that obviously like the fans were
cool with it like everyone everyone lik
liked it yeah and he was just like dude
I'm just going to let you know every
time we're shooting a video what we're
doing like and if you want to get down
yeah pop into whatever you want so um
yeah that's I haven't shot anything else
since that but cuz obviously I'm I'm
like pretty locked into a [__]
schedule of what I'm building the new
clothes the new clothes the new brand
mhm mhm so many I would't even call it a
clothing brand it's just a brand yeah a
lot of things I saw on Xbox yeah that
[__] was sexy super crazy yeah yeah the
craziest Xbox I've ever seen this [__]
would you guys have to take it apart
paint it or did somebody do it for you
yeah I had to go through like a
middleman company to buy the Xboxes and
then and they did designed them oursel
and then we got them to like like do it
to them but we're doing the same thing
with uh cuz we have a '90s drop coming
out and uh we're doing uh 10 Game Boy
Colors oh so it's kind of sick it's like
Game Boy Color but in our color sick
that's great um yeah so for you now you
just kind of have the option whenever
you want to film hey yeah I want to do
the Bigfoot thing or yeah yeah which is
like I never didn't want to do pranks
that's why I did [__] hole why I did
about say when you were doing [__] hole
you did some great [__] like um you had
the old man that I just saw at a random
restaurant in the valley oh eaten Park
in Burbank I was there with my parents
and I saw that old dude who was like oh
Gramps yeah yeah yeah yeah Gramps and I
was just
like that's the dude well he's like a
straight up actor tons of [__] a great
[__] actor but yeah no I saw him I
was like that's the [__] old man for
the [__] uh the the the Jesse videos
yeah yeah I mean [__] hole was dope I
mean for you at the
moment documenting kind of the new what
Sunday is right the brand you've been
putting so much into so much work into I
told you off camera I was like it's
crazy cuz I kind of feel like I've just
been
watching this thing since like
incubation just come live on YouTube and
now you're obviously having success you
had the pop-up shop yeah um Rose it
feels like everything's just flying I
mean you know you drop and it sells out
yeah um and uh for you like I guess what
is
your you have so much going on you train
you're working out you got the brand
you're shooting Vlogs content all of
that what is kind of like your like most
of your energy going into because you
also eventually want to kind of help do
stuff for other brands right yeah we're
currently already doing that right now
oh dope just we uh we slowed down at the
start like the like you were saying You'
seen like you it feels like you like
know Sunday from the start you can like
feel how the whole operation works we
got like I've said this before but like
that's why we got so much hate on it cuz
it was like we were so transparent that
we like didn't even know what the
[__] company was like we were
figuring it out and people were seeing
us figure it out which again I think
long term is paying off cuz now people
are like wo now I now I understand all
the moving Parts but um yeah the the
only thing with the working for other
people and designing their [__] is it is
super complicated
unless if you do if you do six out of 10
things for that company and they
commission you to do that but then they
[__] up the other four and it doesn't
sell or it doesn't work and it's they
yeah and they want to blame you for not
working and you're like well you didn't
know how to mark it or you didn't know
how to you know whatever it was whatever
so I think the key is coming in and in
the future it'll be like Venture Studio
absorbing companies like taking half
their company small that we believe in
and so that we help build them up yeah
and we can do everything for them but
like if you kind of become a partner and
you make it vertical fully vertical and
don't do too many of them just like true
yeah don't take on too much cuz then
you're going to I mean everything gets
watered down if you're going to do that
you know what I'm saying yo it's crazy
because I remember the way you were
talking about like the blank and how
important it was to find the right blank
yeah and like what like did you guys
have to because there's so many blanks
out there there's like Los Angeles
apparel and uh
uh is La apparel the big thick one that
I like pause super pause
yeah um but like for you guys skon all
yeah yeah all that right so like how did
you find the blank or did you create the
blank create everything's created so
everything we sell is completely custom
but it's uh I would say it it's a
Frankenstein of a bunch of different
shirts so like For That t-shirt it was
like it has a little bit of an acne
Studios blank it like that's where the
boxy fit came the the fabric was like
some shirts that we liked but it was
also came down to just Tyler who was
part of our sourcing team who just he
knows every single fabric we go field
Fabrics like we sampled that shirt like
12 times so it just kept frankensteining
until we were like this is the perfect
shirt at a perfect price point and do
you go to China to feel Fabrics just
curious I haven't yet no feel he he is
our like connection to that he he's the
guy who's got the Chinese plugs yeah but
we're also doing a lot of [__]
domestically too we're trying to as much
as we can I mean that's dope yeah if you
don't have to Outsource and you can
support some American companies why
wouldn't you no 100% you or North
American companies cuz shout out to
Canada yeah we're all in this together
you know and
Mexico